[Music]
sorry stop farting and [ __ ] and
chairs here hello reject nation it's
Greg Alva here this is Tara Eric said it
army awakened guys I got a lot of
requests and Benjamin warned a patreon
he's the one who said everyone wants to
react to this one so I checked the
comments on the greatest showmen this is
me reaction from Australia and sure yeah
that's a great so I was like well Tara
hasn't seen the greatest showmen so I
might as well show her the video that I
reacted to and then I'm crying again at
the damn baby
so Moshe put it on patreon book we're
gonna watch the other requested one
right now from now on this one's sung by
Hugh Jackman here we go I don't know if
this once we managed to get this day
Hugh calls me the day before and says
that I cut out of my nose all was fine I
knew you
see I explained away from while was the
scene I also explained this was Michael
suggesting on it that I should stand
just to be clear to everyone that I will
be singing on the day and gesticulated
and and of course act all the scenes and
he did yes it to his credit he did that
make every single number he's got then
he was the great showman until one
number
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Music]
as crazy
[Music]
bleating bleating I don't think so
it looks getting better
[Music]
damn that root is shaky is going love it
[Music]
oh my god now he's wiping he's got sighs
he's bleeding
Madras back for him did they make what
about zendaya she's the one that was
like was she the one I'm not sure I know
it's already respected the crap out of
Hugh Jackman and now I respect it even
more slain to be slaying in there just
like on stitches he had 50 stitches in
his nose he was told he shouldn't be
singing and he did it anyway and he
helped get this movie greenlit with that
specific performance that we just saw
right there greatest showman that's a
leader right there that's a leader
that's a hero for everyone right there
you know even though I don't love the
greatest showman I think it should win
an Oscar for one of its songs I really
do I was moved yeah
by both that we watch we watched - it's
cool to see the first time I Keala
issues more the underdog you know she's
not as well-known and she's being given
this opportunity to help greenlight the
movie yeah this is all this pressure on
her to do it but then they got Hugh
Jackman who's a star who could handle
this on any healthy day like it's
nothing right but then he has a day
where he's recovering he just got skin
cancer removed from his nose but he has
to be a leader he's the lead of the
movie and he's a producer so he has to
make this happen forever yeah so he's
just like okay to start with the doctor
said despite the fact that I'm gonna be
bleeding I have to make this happen so
the behind the scenes of this movie just
gets me to appreciate the [ __ ] out of
this any more than I did when I just
watch the movie on its own I'm glad that
I've been seeing it yeah and then I
watch it right before I I'm gonna go see
it I'm really Fe yes gives you a
different lens oh my god sure does I'm
on the inside that was so cool
he's so great why it's he just like oh
he's there yeah so in it he has a work
ethic man so method I don't know if
that's method do you know what method
Emile you know I understand into the I
disagree I believe he did turn into the
because I didn't see new jackman anymore
I saw the greatest showman I think more
depth he had stitches on his nose that's
you know I'll give you that he was not
dressed like PT Barnum very cool I
didn't need the clothes because method
would mean you have the clothes to you
know to really get any character okay
listen this way oh and you're in your
head okay in your in your head I don't
need the costume because I'm the great
showman no matter what I'm wearing no
matter what I'm saying singing he just
is the greatest showman that's method
have I changed your subscriber the real
researcher Erich said on the terror
Ericsson YouTube channel become a part
of her idiot army so much yeah I'm sure
you guys already belong come join me
thanks for the requests fellow patron
what's his name Brian and he's from
Australia and your eyes I remembered
your name it's like Brian Williamson I
know I don't have a very good memory
Benjamin walrus or you got a great
Australian accent was real I didn't get
you a book on method acting that call
back in about four times so I don't
think any guy think I'm a professional
that's method when it comes to manage